quel smartphone acheté au mois de
décembre il y a des nouveautés qui sont
arrivées il y a des tarifs qui changent
par rapport au mois précédent vous allez
voir c'est extrêmement intéressant dans
cette vidéo on va venir segmenter moins
de 200 € 200 à 500 500 jusqu'à 900 plus
de 900 on regardera un côté le gaming on
regardera également les smartphones
pliables c'est une vidéo qui est
chapitrée allez jeter un coup d'œil
juste en bas dans la description vous
avez le chapitrage qui est juste là
comme ça vous saurez tout vous pourrez
aller là où vous voulez puis bien
évidemment si un de ces produits vous
intéresse je vous mets tous les liens en
bas dans la description pour aller vous
faire plaisir allez on commence par les
moins de 200 balles et par une nouveauté
c'est un produit qu'on m'envoyé je
connaissais absolument pas c'est une
marque qui s'appelle SPC d'ailleurs je
sais pas si vous connaissiez cette
marque dites-le mooi dans dans les
commentaires c'est un peu le feu Wiko
espagnol à mon avis on est sur un
produit qui coûte
169,90 € et que je trouve déjà un tarif
intéressant tuàdire que sur la
Marketplace de la FNAC je l'ai à
1647 c'est de la marketplace ça vient
d'Espagne alors ce qui est intéressant
avec ce produit c'est le grand écran de
6,8 pouces et le capteur principal de 50
mégapixel on a 6 Go de RAM 128 Go de
stockage une grosse batterie de 5000
mamph bon c'est un produit que je suis
en train de tester que je suis en train
de regarder je peux pas vous donner mon
retour tout de suite complet mais moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est le tarif de la
recharge power dellivr 18 W le site est
un peu de chip l'emballage est pas
foufou mais une fois de plus 169 €.
ensuite on continue avec les produits
qu'on connaît et ça c'est très cool
redmi note 12 de Xiaomi là il y a une
différence de prix ça bouge si vous
regardez sur la version 464 il est tombé
à 179 ,90 € qui enfin super bon plan moi
ce que je vous conseille quand même
c'est de mettre les 20 balles de plus et
de passer sur le 400 28 on a toujours
besoin de stockage et comme c'est un
smartphone que vous allez garder au
moins 2 ans voire 3 ans et peut-être
même 4 ans allez savoir et bien ça vaut
le coup d'avoir 128 Go de stockage sans
quoi vous pourriez galérer donc ça c'est
quand même vachement bien le tarif est
super super super canon on reste dans
les moins de 200 balles et on va aller
voir chez Samsung sur le A14 4G sur les
smartphones 4G attention ici quand je
vous parle du redmi note 12 c'est un 4G
du A14 c'est un 4G et bien évidemment là
le A14 4G il une version 5G mais tout de
suite on en parle pas là on est à 199 €
là-dessus il était tombé à 179 € pendant
la période de Black Friday là il a
remonté un petit peu mais il est quand
même un tarif un peu maintenu ça reste
un très joli smartphone également qui
est assez complet avec un grand écran de
6,6 pouces bref voilà c'est efficace
c'est pas foufou en photo mais ça fait
le T et si sur votre Smartphone vous
voulez regarder des courses de F1 ou
encore des match de foot gratuitement
c'est totalement possible il est même
possible de venir trouver un abonnement
à YouTube Premium ou Spotify moins cher
de payer moins cher votre location de
voiture votre prochain voyage et tout ça
grâce au sponsor de cette vidéo Norv VPN
parce que N VPN vous permet de changer
virtuellement d'emplacement vous faites
donc croire à différents sites Web et
services que vous êtes dans un are pays
vous péerez donc les abonnements au
tarif du pays où vous vous connectez et
non pas de celui où vous êtes
physiquement mais il y a également de
gros avantages à dire prendre un
abonnement à nvpn notamment pour votre
sécurité en ligne par exemple si vous
venez vous connecter dans un Wii public
et bien nvpn va venir vous assurer un
anonymat en créant un tunnel crypté et
sécurisé où personne ne pourra voir ce
que vous êtes en train de faire faire
sur le web mais ça va encore plus loin
puisque norvpen va venir bloquer les
téléchargements suspects donc s'il une
tentative de fishing et bien vous vous
ferez pas avoir ça ça arrive notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux vous recevez un
message qui vous intrigue si vous
cliquez dessus paf on va venir vous
pirater et grâce à N VPN et bien ça
n'arrivera pas et ça va encore plus loin
puisque norvpn va venir scanner le Dark
web pour voir si vos données
personnelles ont fuité au quel cas il
vous alertera et vous allez pouvoir
venir vous changer vos mot de passe pour
être totalement tranquille profitez
d'une offre exceptionnelle pour venir
prendre un abonnement à norvpen pensez
donc à venir sécuriser votre connexion
payer moins cher vos abonnements en plus
de ça vous pouvez venir connectter
jusqu'à six appareils en simultané et
leur offre est satisfait ou remboursé
sous 30 jours pensez donc à venir
prendre un abonnement à norvpin je vous
mets bien évidemment un lien juste en
bas dans la description ensuite dans les
plus de 200 € dans les 200 à 500 € on va
commencer doucement doucement par le
tarif on va rester pour l'instant chez
Samsung avec le grand frère du A14 4G
c'est le A14 5G qui a 249 € pareil éc
6,6 pouces capteur principal de 50
mégapixel on va gagner un petit peu en
perf ça reste pas foufou non plus mais
c'est efficace moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est le A23 5G qui lui est passé de 329
€ à 269 € c'est la génération de l'année
encore d'avant mais qui reste encore
très actuel le tarif est très canon ici
vous avez surtout un grand écran de 6,6
pouces un taux de rafraîchissement 120
Hz donc ça c'est quand même vachement
bien pour le gaming un dragon 195 c'est
correct toujours chez Samsung avant
d'aller voir ce qui se passe du côté de
chez Xiaomi on est à 349 € 399 € sur le
Galaxy A34 5G alors vous savez on
augmente un palier par palier on
augmente un peu les specs vous avez une
dalle de 6,6 pouces un écran de 120 Hz
également capteur de 48 mégapixel ok
vous allez avoir un ultra grand Tang de
8 mégapixel versus 5 mégapixel sur le
A23 voilà il est résistant al bon voilà
et là on monte encore d'un cran en tarif
sur le Galaxy A54 5G qui était à 499 qui
est tombé à 449 € qui est vraiment une
très très très jolie proposition dans le
milieu de gamme qui est assez complet en
fait avec un bel écran de 6,4 pouces 100
Hz une fois de plus capteur principal
stabilisé de 50 mégapixel bon ok je vous
passe un peu les spec mais c'est
vraiment un très joli smartphone dans le
milieu de gamme si vous voulez
l'expérience Samsung ici l'expérience
logiciel Samsung et l'écosystème Samsung
avec pourquoi pas et on sait que Samsung
travaille énormément là-dessus mononde
connecté tablette télé réfrigérateur
plaque et compagnie voilà donc ça c'est
plutôt cool alors il y en a un qui s'est
bien bougé aussi c'est Xiaomi avec son
redmi note 12 qui a bougé qui était à
299 qui est tombé pendant le Black
Friday à 200 même un petit peu avant à
269,90 € qui maintenant est à
219,90 € c'est une très jolie
proposition alors c'est un 428 si on
veut avoir un peu plus de fluidité on va
passer sur le 8 256 c'est 20 balles de
plus franchement si vous avez
239,90 € passer sur le 8256 vous gagnez
en fluidité et en stockage c'est quand
même énorme vous avez un écran i de 6,67
pouces c'est de la molette 120 Hz c'est
la recharge rapide 33 W bon le Pr c'est
pas fou mais il fait le taf très jolie
proposition grosse batterie bon c'est ce
qu'on attend le smartphone dans cette
gamme de prix après il y a le modèle Pro
qui était à 3 99 qui était tombé à 329 €
qui maintenant est à 299 € je vous le
dis Xiaomi c'est à peu près le moment où
ils vont sortir les nouveaux redmi note
redmi note 13 qui devrait pas tarder à
arriver j'ai pas d'info mais c'est
toujours un peu dans cette période là
c'est pour ça à mon avis qu'il viennent
finir les stocks et écouler en cassant
un peu les prix donc ça peut valoir le
coup de venir se positionner dessus 828
en plus à 299 € c'est quand même super
bien si on veut gagner un petit peu en
fluidité on vient rajouter 10 balles ça
peut valoir le coup une fois de plus
quand on pense à garder son smartphone
un peu plus longtemps dans le temps
c'est toujours une dalle de 6 67 pouces
le capteur est beaucoup mieux au niveau
de la photo c'est l'IMX 766 de Sony qui
est très très bon la recharge encore
plus rapide un écran AMOLED 120 Hz bref
super proposition à moins de 300 balles
et puis après on vient se mettre en face
je dirais du Galaxy A54 c'est le redmi
note 12 Pro plus 5G qui était à 499 €
donc ça veut dire que c'est le prix en
fait auquel vous allez retrouver ici à
quelque chose près le Galaxy A54 sauf
que ils sont extrêmement agressif il le
tombe à
399,90 € sur un 8 256 € toujours les
dalles de 6,67 pouces caméra 200
mgapixel stabilisée de la charge 120 W
écran AMOLED 120 Hz bref c'est une
petite bombe techniquement sont
extrêmement bien positionnés et ça reste
un super bon plan et si un de ces
produits vous intéresse n'oubliez pas je
vous mets tous les liens juste en bas
dans la description alors il y a un
autre produit qui m'intéresse que je
trouve très beau très élégant va plus
dans un côté un peu plus design c'est le
Honor Magic 5 Lite sauf que lorsque je
regarde ce smartphone je vois qu'en 68
je suis à 379 € et je me dis c'est un
peu cher et que je regarde la config 8
200 56 je passe à
299,90 € les tarifs baissent
drastiquement alors que vous allez
monter au niveau du smartphone 80 €
d'écart en moins c'est super intéressant
et c'est un smartphone que je trouve
très très très très très joli il va être
incurvé au LED 120 Hz j'aime bien le
design également à l'arrière une grosse
batterie de 5100 mahh il est puissant il
est performant il fait plutôt de bonnes
photos aussi et à
299 € 90 c'est vraiment un des gros
smartphones que je vais venir
recommander ici dans cette config que je
trouve super intéressant in en tarif si
vous avez un budget un peu moins de 300
balles vous allez ici sur le Honor Magic
5 Lite si vous avez un budget un peu
moins de 400 balles qu'on veut venir
monter en spec vous allez sur le redmi
note 12 Pro plus 5G qui est aussi super
bien du coup tout ça ça vient un peu
disqualifier le Honor 90 qui est un
excellent smartphone mais qui coûte
quand même quasiment 500 balles et vu
les specs bon alors il est bien il est
complet il est polyvalent je l'aime bien
c'est un très très joli smartphone mais
à peu près à 500 balles donc là-dessus
c'est pas forcément ce que je vais venir
tout de suite en tout cas vous
recommander voyez les tarifs boug et ça
change quand même pas mal de choses
alors attention h pro ok super cool
c'est un smartphone de l'année dernière
c'est le nothing phone one qui est tombé
à 329 € qui était à 399 le mois dernier
et qui une fois de plus reste super
super super super intéressant c'est
vraiment un super milieu de gamme avec
la glyf interface derrière c'est un
produit qui est très différent par
rapport à ce qu'on retrouve sur le reste
du marché si vous voulez un produit cool
joli et une fois de plus je vous mets
les liens des vidéos que j'ai fait sur
ces smartphones en bas dans la
description alors il y en a un qui est
cool qui est sorti il y a pas longtemps
également c'est le Motorola c'est le 40
néo coûte 399 € qui reste plutôt bien
placé ici il y a différentes couleurs
moi j'aime bien celui-là c'est le canil
Bay que je vous avais déjà présenté et
qui est juste magnifique qui bosse avec
Panton ici vous avez une dalp AMOLED
6,55 pouces et c'est vrai quand on vient
le mettre en face d'un Xiaomi un redmi
note 12 Pro plus à 399 € voyez c'est
exactement le même tarif ça lui fait un
petit peu mal et lorsqu'on se met face à
un Honor Magic 5 Lite en 8 256 qui a
encore 100 balles de moins ça lui fait
peu mal quand même aussi donc ici on
vient retenir chez Samsung le A23 5G 269
€ le Honor Magic 5 Lite à 299 € le noing
phone one à 329 € et puis ensuite on va
aller sur le redmi note 12 Pro plus 5G à
399 € c'est hyper canon et là déjà vous
avez une super vision d'ensemble sur les
tarifs 200 à 500 balles on va regarder
maintenant les 500 à 900 €. le premier
que je vais venir vous recommander qui
est top on est un peu plus de 500 balles
c'est le pixel 7a je vous l'avais déjà
présenté une fois de plus si vous voulez
une expérience 100 % Google avec de la
photographie computationnelle c'est de
Lia derrière sur votre photo c'est
Google qui FAA des traitements
automatiques pour optimiser toutes vos
photos avec une superbe expérience
logiciel à 509 € pixel 7a vous pouvez y
aller les yeux fermés il y en a un qui a
baissé aussi en tarif qui est canon
c'est le grand frère du phone one de
noing que je vous ai présenté tout à
l'heure c'est le noing phone 2 phone 2
qui était à 849 € qui est tombé à 699 €
le tarif est juste fou en fait ici vous
avez un smartphone une fois de plus très
joli glyf interface SOS extrêmement
actuel de grosse grosse grosse
performance je dirais qu'il est un peu
moins bon en photo c'est truc où il va
pas être foufou il reste correct
attention mais il lui manque un petit
truc dal ltpo AMOLED 6,7 pouces et il
est totalement magnifique voilà ça c'est
vraiment la très très grosse force de ce
produit c'est son look son design vous
pouvez venir composer vos musiques vous
allez avoir un minuteur qui va descendre
qui va venir s'afficher un affichage
particulier en fonction d'un appel enfin
bref on peut venir personnaliser
énormément de choses et c'est un produit
que j'aime énormément autre smartphone
que je viens recommander beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup énormément plus plus
plus c'est c'est le Asus c'est le
zenfone 10 799 € il était tombé à 699 €
pendant le Black Friday il est remonté
un petit peu mais ça reste un tout petit
smartphone on est à moins de 6 pouces
5,9 pouces et des smartphones à moins de
6 pouces aujourd'hui il y en a pas
énormément sur le marché en plus de ça
il a beaucoup de performance Snapdragon
8 gen 2 des super caméras très belle
expérience logiciel également ici donc
c'est vraiment un produit qui en plus
des couleurs que j'aime bien qui sont
très très cool qui est super intéressant
qui est compact donc si vous cherchez un
smartphone un peu plus petit coucou
d'ailleurs il y a ma tronche ici et bien
vous pouvez aller sur le zenfone 10 de
Asus à 799 €. autre produit qui est
sorti il y a pas longtemps c'est Xiaomi
13t é à 649 € il tombe à 549,90 € ce qui
enfin un smartphone qui est quand même
supra intéressant et puis vous avez son
grand frère alors c'est un peu plus
compliqué avec son grand frère le 13t
pro qui coûte
899,90 € vous allez voir qu'il y a pas
mal de changement du côté de chez
Samsung sur les S23 il arrivé d'un
nouveau produit dans la gamme qui fait
que c'est un peu plus dur pour ce
produit-là il y a beaucoup de monde dans
ce segment de prix on est quasiment à
900 balles j' dirais plus sur le Xiaomi
13t et un peu moins sur le Xiaomi 13 pro
le Galaxy S23 fe est aussi une très très
jolie proposition nouveau smartphone de
Samsung on l'attendait il y a eu le S21
fe il y a pas eu de S22 fe et puis il
reviennent en force avec cette gamme Fe
au niveau du S23 c'est en fait comme un
S23 mais un peu plus light on aura par
contre un écran un peu plus grand 6,4
pouces contre 6,1 pouces sur le S23 au
lieu d'avoir un Snapdragon 8 gen 2 on
aura un exyos 2200 5G bien évidemment
gravé ici en 4 nanomè au lieu d'avoir un
cornoria glace victus 2 on aura un
corningoria glace 5 au lieu d'avoir un
taux de rafraîchissement qui va aller
entre 48 et 120 Hz on va faire du 60 120
Hz au lieu d'avoir un téléobjectif de 10
mgapixel on aura 8 mgapixel en fait vous
l'avez compris c'estant S23 un peu plus
light et qui est proposé dans des
coloris super chatoyantes regardez il y
en a vraiment de tous les côtés il y a
également des couleurs exclusives qui
sont disponibles uniquement sur le site
de Samsung bien évidemment je vous mets
un lien juste en bas dans la description
je vais essayer de faire tire tout ça
dans mes mains c'est un peu compliqué il
y en a vraiment pour tous tous les goûts
le design est très très proche de celui
du Galaxy S23 on reprend les codes de la
gamme S alors bien évidemment je vous
donne tous les détails de ce smartphone
très bientôt surtout ce qui est
intéressant c'est son prix 828 on est à
689 et 8 256 759 €. il est très bien
positionné mais un tarif qui est assez
proche du Galaxy S23 donc soit vous avez
100 € de plus et vous allez sur le S23
soit vous ne les avez pas vous allez sur
le Galaxy S23 fe mais dans tous les cas
vous serez pas déçu après pour plus de
détails il y a la vidéo qui sort très
très bientôt donc restez connectés sur
la chaîne le Galaxy S23 a baissé il
était à la base à 959 € il est tombé 799
€ dans la version 828 alors j'avais fait
une vidéo il y a une différence entre la
version 828 et la version 8 256 au
niveau des techn de stockage et de
mémoire allez voir ma vidéo d'ailleurs
sur sur Youtube très honnêtement à 799 €
ça reste un très très joli smartphone
Snapdragon 8 gen 2 on est chez Qualcomm
ici ça marche du feu de dieu et la très
très bonne nouvelle c'est le Galaxy S23
plus en 8 256 qui était à 1219 € qui est
tombé à 899 € ça veut dire que vous avez
100 balles d'écart entre un S23 et un
S23 plus et ce qui est ouf c'est que
vous avez le S23 F qui est arrivé qui
lui est à 699 € et la strate de Samsung
ici elle est très claire chaque
smartphone se fait une différence d'un
palier de 100 € S23 F 699 S23 799 S23
plus 899 ça vient un peu péter les
pattes à la concurrence et ça permet à
Samsung de se positionner ici sur tout
ces tarifs là ce qui fait que et bien ça
fait beaucoup de mal à Xiaomi avec son
Xiaomi 13t pro qui est à 799 mais
également au Xiaomi 13 donc bon voyez
c'est des smartphones on va un peu moins
regarder ça fait aussi beaucoup de mal à
Motorola avec ses hedge40 et hed40 pro
puisque le H40 est à 599 € et le H40 pro
à 899 €. là ça disqualifie d'emblé par
contre il y a deux propos qui sont super
intéressantes chez Google pixel 8 pixel
8 Pro alors pourquoi vous allez me dire
pixel 8 Pro on verra après parce que
c'est plus de 900 balles mais le pixel 8
à 799 € c'est intéressant pourquoi et
bien parce que en fait ils prennent les
choses un peu différemment des autres
ils ont leur puce maison c'est la Google
10ensor c'est la G3 qu'on va venir
retrouver ici toute la photo raphie
computationnelle tout ce qu'on va
pouvoir venir faire avec la gomme
magique avec un smartphone dédié à lia
ici au niveau de la photo et de la vidéo
un smartphone 100 % pensé pour les
usages que Google pense que vous devez
avoir de son smartphone et à 799 € ça
reste très très bon alors bien
évidemment une fois de plus je reviens
sur le smartphone que je vous disais
tout à l'heure à 509 € qui est très cool
c'est le pixel 7a mais pourquoi pas si
vous avez un peu plus de budget et bien
vous irez un peu plus loin ici avec
votre pixel alors après il y a la
question des iPhones les iPhones c'est
aussi un sujet intéressant parce que si
vous voulez un smartphone un peu compact
vous allez sur l'iPhone mais ce la 3è
génération c'est un look très old school
ça reste un petit smartphone en taille
529 € directement ici franchement ça
vaut le coup après vous avez l'iPhone 13
tarif canon qui est à 749 € qui tombe à
699 € qu'on peut trouver iciite sur la
Fnac alors bientôt en stock ils vont
arriver donc bon ça vaut le coup aller
jeter un œil l'iPhone 14 également qui
était à 869 € qu'on peut trouver à 819 €
et puis bien évidemment l'iPhone 15 qui
est à 969 € alors petite astuce si vous
voulez un iPhone 15 allez plutôt sur un
iPhone 14 pro Pro vous irez plus loin en
terme de photo ça sera exactement la
même puce à l'intérieur donc au lieu de
prendre un iPhone 15 vous prenez un
iPhone 14 pro et ici pas de mauvaise
surprise alors là je vous ai passé un
petit peu les 900 balles on va revenir
légèrement en arrière pour vous
présenter un smartphone qui est cool
crossc stellar X5 alors c'est pas un
produit fait pour tout le monde c'est un
produit qui va être fait pour les gens
qui veulent faire de l'outdoor qui
veulent un produit un peu différent on
peut aller se baigner avec vous avez t
des modes qui sont réfléchis si est
pensé par crossc pour venir faire de la
vidéo sous-marine si on le souhaite ENF
voilà il y a pas mal de choses c'est un
jhui aussi bien pour des gens qui
veulent un smartphone exigeant avec
toutes les dernières techno ici Wii 6 e
et compagnie à un peu moins de 900
balles surtout un nouveau parti prix ici
de la part de crossc et ça on aime à
plus de 900 € maintenant il y a quelques
smartphones qui m'intéressent il y en a
deux principaux que je vais venir
retenir alors on regarde ça on regarde
les pliable après et puis on va regarder
ensuite les smartphon de gaming Honor
Magic 5 Pro que je continue à énormément
aimer même si c'est un smartphone du
début de l'année qui était présenté au
mois de février ça reste un super
smartphone et là il est un peu moins de
1000 balles
999,90 € ça vaut vraiment le coup 12 256
très cool en photo bref c'est vraiment
un des gros coup de cœur ici cette année
que je mettrai en face d'un Samsung d'un
Galaxy S23 ultra qui lui coûtait quand
même 1419 € qui est tombé à 1199 € mais
voyez il y a 200 balles d'écart entre
ces produits donc ça reste quand même un
gros budget si vous pouvez pas monter
au-dessus des 1000 balles et bien vous
allez sans regret sur le Honor Magic 5
Pro maintenant le mus du must pour moi
ça reste quand même le Galaxy S23 ultra
avec un S Pen j'en ai pas besoin moi
mais j'adore ce smartphone pu je vous
disais bien évidemment les iPhones
iPhone 14 pro max iPhone 15 on est à
plus de 900 balles et ça reste une fois
de plus ici des grosses références dans
l'univers des smartphones qui se plie il
y a vraiment deux produits qu'on va
retenir mais surtout un principal c'est
le Galaxy zflip 5 qui est super bien qui
est à 1199 € ce qui est intéressant chez
Samsung en ce moment une fois de plus je
vous mets les liens dans la description
c'est que vous le payez au même prix que
vous preniez le 8256 ou que vous preniez
le 8512 le 512 est au prix du 256 en ce
moment une fois de plus je vous mets
tous les liens juste enas en bas dans la
description al il y en a un autre que
j'ai beaucoup aimé au niveau du du parti
prix c'est ce qu'a proposé Motorola ici
où leur smartphone voyez sur le Razer 40
ultra enfin il y en a plusieurs mais il
y a le Razer 40 c'est vraiment le Razer
40 ultra que j'ai préféré où l'écran il
va venir jusqu'au bout ici ce que ne
fait pas Samsung et je trouve ça quand
même dommage mais il est au même prix et
il ira un peu moins loin les finitions
sert un peu moins bonnes et en photo
c'est un peu moins ça donc à choisir
entre les deux à budget équivalent bien
évidemment ici je vais aller chez
Samsung avec le zflip 5 alors il existe
aussi un autre smartphone qui est
beaucoup plus cher c'est le ZF de 5 qui
est à
1899 € au lieu de 2039 € si on va sur ce
produit là on le sait vous allez pas
forcément venir regarder cette vidéo
pour faire votre choix vous le saurez il
est grand il est beau c'est une espèce
de petite tablette il est magnifique
mais à quasiment 1900 B allez on finit
un peu sur une expérience de gaming avec
différents produits beaucoup de chez
poco mais pas que vous allez voir mon
coup de cœur c'est celui que je vous
présente à la fin il y en a pour tous
les tarifs hein poco X5 5G il était à
249 € on est tombé à partir de 199,90 ça
c'est quand même super cool à molet 120
Hz San drragon du 695 bon c'est efficace
de la recharge rapide la photo on oublie
c'est un peu pourri mais une fois de
plus on est à moins de 200 balles et
pour commencer à rentrer dans l'univers
du gaming c'est plutôt pas mal on a la
version professionnelle on va un peu
plus loin en terme de perf avec un
Snapdragon 798 gG pour gaming c'est la
gamme gaming de Qualcom qui est très
cool 349 € alors là je l'avais le mois
dernier à 299 € pour le coup vous voyez
il est retourné à son tarif d'avant qui
est un peu con mais bon c'est comme ça
c'est plus Black Friday vous avez le F5
qui était à 399 € qu'on a on lit très
très mal qui a 369,90 € Snapdragon 7
plus gen 2 on monte toujours une fois de
plus en terme de de performance amolet
120 Hz bon les photos on oublie une fois
de plus c'est pas fou fou monte en gamme
ici chez poco et puis vous avez alors le
F5 pro Snapdragon 8 plus Gen 1 super
puce ici qui est très très bonne écran
AMOLED c'est du 2K 120 Hz
479,90 € on monte en tarif mais si vous
voulez faire un gros focus sur la
performance pour venir jouer un tarif à
moins de 500 balles on s'en fout un peu
de la la photo poco F5 pro ouais c'est
vraiment super super bien on faire un
énorme bon en avant chez Asus le rock
Phone 7 qui reste pour moi la référence
de gaming dans tous les produits que
j'ai pu tester 1029 € Snapdragon 8 gen 2
la RAM c'est la
lpddr5x 12 Go de RAM c'est juste de la
folie et alors ce qui est intéressant si
vous ne connaissez pas ces produits la
la photo c'est un peu NAS soyons clair
ici vous avez une expérience déjà
visuelle vous allez avoir les air
trigger qui sont des petits boutons en
plus que vous allez avoir ici qui sont
juste top le refroidissement est
vraiment très très très bon vous pouvez
rajouter un ventilateur externe
l'aéroactive couleur 7 vous allez
pouvoir en plus avoir dessus des
gâchettes en plus pouvoir venir brancher
un casque en jack dedans enfin bon voilà
c'est c'est c'est une petite bombe 6000
mamph au niveau de la batterie un écran
molette qui va jusqu'à 165 Hz ça se paye
1029 € une fois de plus en photo vous
oubliez c'est pas ouf mais que ce soit
l'écran la performance la gestion de la
température vous avez vraiment un
smartphone qui est ouf ici et que
personnellement j'adore voilà pour cette
vision à 360° des smartphones à venir
choisir au mois de décembre alors vous
allez voir il y a plein de choses qui
vont arriver au mois de janvier des
nouveaux produits dès lancement il y en
a qui arrivent de tous les côtés il a
déjà des produits que j'ai de côtés mais
je peux pas vous en parler je vous le
dis pas il y en a qui arver là-bas mais
je peux pas vous le dire on se retrouve
bien évidemment en janvier pour regarder
tout ça puis bien évidemment il y a
plein d'autres vidéos plein d'autres
choses qui arrivent sur la chaîne donc
restez connectés pensez à vous abonner
et puis là au moment où je fais cette
vidéo alors elle est pas encore sortie
mais elle va pas tarder à arriver c'est
le test du Galaxy S23 F il va arriver là
dès que la vidéo sera prête je mettrai
là en attendant je vous mets autre chose
allez voir cette vidéo du nouveau
smartphone de Samsung le Galaxy S23 F
parce que c'est pas tous les mois qu'on
va arriver un nouveau smartphone de
Samsung dans la gamme Galaxy S et ça on
aime